you were deployed to iraq
were there any memories experiences that
changed you
or in general like you're probably a
different man on the other side of it
how did that time change you i think
there was two main
takeaways that i took right so one was
um not a specific moment but on multiple
occasions
uh i remember we were driving down the
road and i would look and there would be
a
10 12 14 year old kid and if you've
never seen somebody who
literally has hate and disdain in their
eyes towards you
just not necessarily to you personally
just to the uniform to what you stand
for to all this stuff
when you see it you see it right and i
always think of
if you've ever uh watched the movie a 12
strong
and in it they've got this afghan
afghanistan warlord and he's
talking to a bunch of soldiers and he
says you know you don't have killer eyes
you do you do and he's just like he can
just tell right he's seen so many
soldiers and so i think that
that was a a memory on a number of
occasions where i just saw a young kid
and i just said they hate us right and
and it's not you personally it's what
you stand for but the the really big
event was
when you first get to these combat zones
a lot of times what will happen is
uh you basically your unit teams up with
a unit that's leaving
and there's a handoff and it happens
over a couple of weeks and so you can
imagine almost
you know one percent of our team goes
out with 99 of their team then 5
95 10 90 all the way until it's 50 50
and then eventually it rotates and then
it's majority of our team and
a small number of their team and so what
a lot of people will explain is the two
most dangerous times in war
are actually the first two or three
weeks in the last two or three weeks
when you first get there you don't know
who the people are you don't know the
terrain you don't know
you know kind of the local cultures and
and who to look out for what signs all
that kind of stuff
and the last two or three weeks is you
basically think you've survived the
deployment you're looking forward to
going home so you become complacent
things like that
and so we made it through that
transition period with no issues
but the literally the very first mission
uh that we went out as a team ourselves
100
there was two separate incidents uh one
was we were driving the mill tonight
and uh what we think was a sniper shot
at a truck that i was in i was standing
up outside of it
uh along with a another guy and that was
kind of just a wake-up call again of
never been shot up before right and so
i'll never forget
uh you kind of heard this whiz go by and
the guy next to me was from
rural pennsylvania and he just said you
know look i've never been shot at before
either i've done a lot of hunting get
the [ __ ] down
okay and so uh we kept driving that
night
um and uh later on in the night
uh an ied went off a guy ran over an ied
uh who was at the front of the convoy
and when that ied went off uh again i
had never been in a convoy that had been
blown up before
but the training kicks in and so
immediately every single person starts
screaming out ied ied and they start
looking and trying to figure it out and
you realize
the united states military did a
fantastic job training us before we went
because in that moment nobody thought
about anything you just did what you had
been programmed to do
um and so ultimately kind of through the
end of that event
uh there was you a soldier that ended up
dying he was shot in the head
and um when we got back to the base uh
kind of after that entire event
i think it just hit us we are at war and
if we make mistakes here
that is the cost of you know kind of
those mistakes
and this was somebody who i didn't know
uh it was somebody who literally showed
up
kind of as secondary support for our
unit
and basically was there to help us right
and so it was one of those weird
situations where
you have this emotional connection
because it's somebody who
shared an event with you but you didn't
know them right and you learn their name
later
and you understand that they have a
family and they have young kids and all
this stuff
and so again as a 20 year old kid you're
kind of processing all this and you just
realize like
the gun i have in my arm my hands it's
real for a reason
right and we better take this seriously
this is not you know let's joking around
in kind of the barracks and
you know all the things that you would
expect you know guys are doing the army
so i think that was like the moment
where i said hey i'm gonna learn a lot
here
uh and i gotta make sure i get home and
you snapping into the training
but nevertheless i mean you're somebody
who thinks philosophically about this
world now
right you're uh very intelligent and
thinks deeply about
the world so looking back you mentioned
hatred in the 14 year old kids eyes
there's death so the way you kind of
describe this whole story
is like training kicks in this this [ __ ]
is serious
like this is uh you know there's a
reason there's a gun in
in your hand so there's a strategic
element there's like you have to get the
job done there's a task at hand
but the same time if you zoom out
there's a kid
who has hate for you some of those kids
would probably if they could
would kill you for the thing you stand
for in the uniform
and then there's bullets flying at you
and then there's people that some of
them
you might already care for deeply are
dying
what the hell do you make of that
do you think about that does any of that
haunt you
how do you think about the world having
witnessed that
yeah a lot of times when we would talk
about it we were there
if i was that kid i would want to kill
that person too
right i would have hatred as well right
imagine if in the united states
tomorrow you and i woke up and there was
tanks rolling down the street from
another country
yeah and they were basically imposing
their rules on us
whether they thought it was the right
thing to do or not the soldiers were
there they were doing this
we would probably feel not so great
about it right at kind of a minimum and
at a maximum we'd be really really
pissed off we would fight back
and so what you don't understand when
you're in the heat of the moment is
why does this person feel this way and
so what's very weird
is well what happens if a year ago u.s
soldiers came
through they got shot at they returned
fire and they killed that kid's uncle
you'd be pissed off right and so you
just start to understand like
we look at war very black and white we
look at it very much
from a clinical perspective we're going
to go we're going to go
kind of invade somewhere we are the most
dominant military in the world we're
very good at invading
and we will crush wherever we invade but
when you're actually on the ground what
you understand is the humanity of it all
right and so what becomes very
interesting is um
pretty much every veteran i know that
comes back they're some of the largest
pacifists in the world
and i always revert back to uh marcus
latrell who's a famous navy seal
and there's a movie made about him and
his story he gave a speech one time
that i saw and he basically said listen
if you're a politician
your job is to be the diplomat do
everything you possibly can not to send
me and my friends
anywhere because when you send us we're
going to bring hell with us
right and understand that is the
business that we are in
but every single other person up until
we get sent has a job to do to prevent
having to send us
and i think that ultimately that's where
you see a lot of kind of this generation
that is fought in iraq and afghanistan
that says listen maybe we shouldn't be
running around the world being the
police
maybe we shouldn't be going and invading
all these different countries
because when you actually get to see
firsthand what happens
it's just something that we should avoid
at all cost but if we have to go
or we have to actually send soldiers
somewhere
understand what happens when that occurs
and you know the united states is the
best in the world of doing it
you